hi I'm Ted bellacor with reason TV what
do you think of the price tag for
President Obama's health care plan will
cost somewhere on the order of 1
trillion dollars over the next 10 years
1 trillion dollars a trillion dollars a
trillion dollars we hear the one
trillion dollar figure all the time as
if that's what the health care plan
would really end up costing that's real
money even in Washington but remember
the last time Washington performed major
surgery on the health care system we're
traveling the country reminding people
that there is a fantastic opportunity
for our seniors president bush signed
the Medicare prescription drug benefit
into law in 2003 price tag 400 billion
dollars just two months later the Bush
administration announced a new estimate
534 billion cost of this program go up
almost daily all of Washington is
suffering from sticker shock started at
400 billion then I went to 500 billion
now we're at seven hundred and twenty
billion dollars and we're still counting
still counting is right because that 400
billion dollar program now costs 950
billion dollars I think just take a step
back for a second Medicare wasn't
working away I thought of [ __ ] Lyndon
Johnson our fellow Texan signed the bill
President Johnson signed the bill making
it the law of the land July thirtieth
1965 back then politician said Medicare
would cost nine billion dollars by 1990
but when 1990 rolled around the actual
cost was six hundred forty-four percent
higher from boston's Big Dig to just
about any rail transit line seems like
whatever politicians touch ends up
costing way more than expected
the Iraq war the price tag is about two
thousand percent more than advertised
all kinds of government agencies try to
protect consumers from false claims
private companies made it would be nice
if Americans could get some truth in
advertising from our government what are
the chances Congress would pass an anti
sticker shock law it might go something
like this any member of Congress who
sponsored the bill that ends up costing
more than expected is forbidden from
running for re-election because it
doesn't matter if the program digs into
the dirt the 1996 farm bill ended up 151
percent pricier than advertised or
floats beyond the Earth's atmosphere
Space Station seventy-seven percent more
expensive if politicians are in charge
you can bet on stratospheric cost hikes
so should we expect sticker shock from
Obamacare a trillion a trillion 1
trillion 1 trillion dollars who knows
maybe it'll be different this time
around for reason TV I'm Ted bellacor